we know where to find some good
questions we just put a post on our
twitter account and we wait sometimes
you have to kiss a few frogs but it's
worth it or or sometimes you have to
kiss a few frogs that are giving you the
middle finger but sometimes it's worth
it at niada thomas asks should the
dolphins take devonta smith number three
overall
in the 2021 draft before we ponder that
let's hear from brian flores the coach
the dolphins the team that holds that
third pick thanks to the texans
regarding the size or lack thereof of
the heisman trophy winner
so what was the question about his size
as how much is that a hindrance compared
maybe to his his production on the field
and how do you do that
you know dynamic if you're if you're a
good player when i mean you can nitpick
what do you want about a guy's size or
you know
good players are good players good
players cam i think i think we all can
see that this guy's a very good player
he made a lot of players in college he
made a lot of plays in the you know big
games biggest games of the year
and
you know yeah i mean you can nitpick all
day about you know things on people um
he's a very good player and it's been
good getting to know him too he's a good
kid too
yeah look i'm not troubled about the
size and i'm surprised he declined to be
measured or weighed at the senior bowl
today he's going to do it at the alabama
pro day i don't know do they have some
special scale there do they have some
special some special measuring stick are
you gonna be heavier are you gonna be
taller i know how to get heavier trust
me the holidays proved that to me yet
again i don't know how to get taller
short of flying into space for a few
days and letting your spinal column
decompress without gravity to pull it
together other than that i don't know
what he can do but i'm not troubled pi
look i don't care the guy's spectacular
desean jackson still one of the most
explosive players in the nfl in his mid
30s
it's speed it's suddenness it's agility
if they can't get to you they can't hit
you so it doesn't matter how small you
may be shireen
absolutely mike and they're probably
gonna have an opportunity to draft him
and it makes sense on so many levels
heisman trophy winner gonna sell tickets
which you need to do he's a former
teammate of tua at alabama did great
things with tua there and just an
outstanding player so it does make sense
on many many levels if they decide
they're not going quarterback route
which it sounds like they're not with
that third overall pick and of course
they have a later pick in the first
round and can do something with that
pick so it does make sense for the
dolphins to take devonta smith mike
well they can send both picks to the
texans for deshaun watson now smith was
on nfl network earlier today and he said
that he's spoken to tuatangobiloa about
running it back about getting back
together now that assumes that the
dolphins are sold on to over the long
haul but smith an electric player
but we get into these tired old
stereotypes and it's it's it's a cya
process
when it comes to scouting players in the
draft you never want to take that chance
on a guy who's small because then if
he's a bust
what happens you get called into the
principal's office and like why did you
recommend we take the small guy it's too
easy to say
in that setting he failed because he was
small well maybe he would have failed if
he was 6'4 so that that's what it it
seems to be so much serene it's about
scouts covering their butts and they are
afraid
to recommend a guy who if he doesn't
work out it's easier
to dot the line back to
where you were too stupid to recommend a
guy that we never should have wanted
because he's not big enough
usually this conversation is about
quarterbacks mike and i i do wonder if
we would be even having this
conversation if he had measured today
because he's big enough and i don't know
that there's any question about whether
he's big not big or not and i don't know
if it would have been a question if he
actually got there and and measured
today the guy can play and that's the
bottom line
he was spectacular in the first half of
the game
against ohio state he had three
touchdowns 200 plus receiving yards 12
catches and he left only because of a
fluke thing where his fingers got caught
up in an opponent and that had nothing
to do with size uh that had everything
to do with every once in a while and i'm
surprised it doesn't happen more often
your fingers get all jacked up when you
run into somebody at full speed nick
andrews has a question about matthew
stafford and this is a good question on
the surface well and i'm not saying it's
a bad question deeper than the surface
but it's a fair point to ask if khalil
mack jaylen ramsey and jamal adams all
got two first-round picks in trade over
the past couple of years why do people
think that matthew stafford will go for
less than that let me take the first
crack at this one shireen i think he
could go less than that because
this is about the two sides are
definitely going to separate so the
question becomes what's the best offer
that the lions will get from a team that
stafford is willing to play for and it
may just not be two first-round picks we
don't know how many teams are going to
come to the table there's too many other
options out there on the market for for
teams to gravitate toward how many teams
ultimately are going to say we're in on
this we're going to show up for the
auction for the matthew stafford
contract so it has nothing to do with
a team saying well hey we'll just keep
him i mean i think that was the attitude
for some of these other trades no you've
got to give us two first round picture
we're just going to keep him the lions
aren't going to keep him it's too late
for that they've got to find the best
deal that they can make with the team
that stafford will play for and it comes
down to those two teams or three teams
or four teams however many teams to
determine what the price tag is as they
compete with each other
yeah mike first of all it takes a team
to make that offer and i just don't see
a team making that offer of two
first-round picks from matthew steven
the other three players we're talking
about are the are the best or close to
the best players at their positions and
that's why they got what they got and as
you said based on hey we'll just keep
them until you give us an offer we can't
refuse and that's what happened so
when you look at matthew stafford mike
we're all assuming that he's an upgrade
that he's a really good quarterback who
was held down
by the talent around him at detroit are
we certain that's the case i don't know
this guy's made one pro bowl and i know
you texted the other day you were
surprised when you looked that up that
he had only made one jerk golf's made
two pro bowls everybody makes the pro
bowl matthew stafford has made one pro
bowl that came in 2014 the last three
years he's 14 25 and one i would have to
take a deep dive into this guy also his
injury history to determine if he a can
stay on the field and b
why their record was what it was with
matthew stafford at quarterback i do
have a lot of questions
first guy i'd want to talk to if i was
thinking about matthew stafford is
reggie bush because there were two
different things from reggie bush's time
with the lions that stand out to me one
at a time when the lions were struggling
reggie bush who brought a super bowl
ring with him to detroit something the
lions haven't even had the chance to
play for in their history
bush suggested that they have a players
only meeting and stafford's attitude was
uh we don't need one of those okay i'll
defer to the guy who's got the super
bowl win who's been part of a team that
knows how to get to the top of the
mountain secondly when bush was done in
detroit he said that team lacks
chemistry now i don't know
how much of that is on stafford and i
mentioned today on pft live it's
entirely possible in building the team
over the years they neglected to search
for guys who would become leaders
because matthew stafford in the
peyton manning to eli manning scale
where peyton is the sheriff and eli is
the deputy who just wants to go home and
watch seinfeld where does matthew
stafford land i think he's far closer to
eli so you need others who can lead but
i'd want to know why it was that reggie
bush thought that and what kind of a
leader reggie bush thinks matthew
stafford is he played with drew brees he
played with matthew stafford how do they
compare because you better have a great
leadership
arrangement in your coaching staff
sharing and in your locker room if if
you want to get the most out of matthew
stafford because i don't think you can
expect the leadership to come from him
and that's not judgment that's not
criticism that's just reality
and he's got to be an upgrade mic over
either a what you have be what you can
get on the free agent market or in a
different trade with some other team or
see what you can get in the draft so
there are a lot of options for teams to
go out and find quarterbacks so matthew
stafford's got to be your best option
and i just don't think he's going to be
that quote-unquote best option for very
many teams
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports